The Joe Rogan experience.
I guess this is kind of my pet phrase.
We are a species with Amnesia
is my favorite phrase of
we have forgotten so much
more about ourselves than we remember.
And what the process of history and
archeology should really be about is a
process of remembering.
We shouldn't be imposing our ideas of
what we should have been on the past.
We should allow the past
to speak for itself.
And when it does so it speaks eloquently.
Um,
one of the sites that we visited and
explored for America before was sip ant
mound in Ohio. I don't know if
you've ever been there. Do you know?
I've heard of it though, is
an amazing Jamie's from Ohio.
You ever be there? Yeah.
Danny and I were talking about it
earlier. There's seven man. There's a,
there's an aerial view of,
of uh,
that is Correy z.
Here's the thing you see is a beautiful,
you see the head end of separate man.
They're so Santa and I went there
at the summer solstice in 2017.
We were there on June 21st,
2017 and my wife's aunt is a photographer
and we acquired a drone for this
specific purpose and she flew the drone
up 400 feet above serpent mound and we
sat it up there watching the sunset and
what happens on the summer solstice,
and you can only see it
perfectly with a drone there.
There's pictures of it in
the, in the book here. Uh,
what happens on the summer solstice,
you can see it from ground level,
but you get up 400 feet,
you really get it.
The head of that serpent is pointing
directly at a niche in the distant hills
through which the sunsets on the summer
solstice on the longest day of the year.
So it's a, it's a sky ground
alignment perfection that is,
that is taking place there.
It's a beautiful,
it's a beautiful thing to see to watch
that sun majestically sinking down into
the horizon and see this awesome figure
of the serpent gazing directly at it
with its jaws open almost as though
it's about to, about to swallow the sun.
And then we remember that there are other
sites around the world which are also
aligned to key moments of the, of the
solar year aligned to the winter solstice.
For example,
the Temple of Karnak in Upper Egypt.
That kilometer long access targets
exactly the rising point of the sun on the
winter solstice. One of the interesting
things about serpent mound, uh,
and I urge anybody listening to this go
visit serpent mound and especially go
there on the summer solstice
cause that's the moment.
That's the marriage of heaven and earth.
That's when sky and ground unite in,
in majesty at a, at, at,
at, at that place. Um,
but one of the mysteries
of serpent mound concerns,
how old is this mount? Really?
How, how, how far back does it go?
And there have been arguments that uh,
there are a group of archeologists who
would like it to be just a thousand years
old and they attributed to a culture
called the fort ancient culture.
There's another group of archeologists,
in my view, have done much more thorough,
thorough work who attributed
to the Edina culture.
The thing about which goes
back to 2,300 years ago or so,
there's evidence for an earlier
construction enterprise.
It looks like the site has
been continuously reconstructed
and remodeled as we
would do with any sacred site.
If it begins to wear down,
you remodel it and then you get later
organic material being introduced to the
site. That may give you the impression
that the site is only that old.
What's intriguing about serpent mound
is it stands on a natural rich and that
natural ridge, and this is entirely
an accident of heaven and earth,
that Natural Ridge, the
head end of it, if you like,
is naturally oriented to
the summer solstice sunset.
Somebody a long time ago noticed that
natural orientation and they decided to
monumentalize it.
Here was a place where earth whispered
to sky the earth in her own nature,
looked directly at the place on the
horizon where the sun was setting.
This was a highly significant place.
This place mattered,
so they then created serpent mound
on top of it. They memorialized it.
They turned it into a,
into a special special place that human
beings had had a hand in making to honor
the marriage of heaven and earth.
And what I found researching this book
is that serpent mound is not alone in
that respect.
A lot of people are pub puzzled
by Stonehenge in England.
A Stonehenge is built on Salisbury
plain and there are two kinds of big
megaliths that Stonehenge,
one of them are called Saxons and
the other called the bluestones.
The bluestones we know for
sure were brought along way.
They were brought from Wales to
Stonehenge, a distance of about 150 miles.
The sausage ones are found in abundance
on a place called the Marlboro downs,
which is about 20 miles from Stonehenge.
But until very recently it was thought
there were no sauces on Salisbury plain
at all and archeologists
couldn't understand why
Stonehenge wasn't built on the
Marlboro downs weather, whether it's big
Sas and stones, the 20 to 30 10 mega,
we're available locally and
didn't have to be brought there.
Very recent research,
2018 research has provided the answer
that two of those sauces were naturally in
position all the time at at Stonehenge
and they are SAS and stone 16 and the
heel stone.
And if you stand behind Saas and stone
16 and look at the heel stone at dawn on
the summer solstice,
you see the sun rising in direct alignment
with the view and the heel stone is
like the site on the barrel of a rifle
targeting the sun and that was there
naturally earth was speaking to sky.
The ancients saw that they
decided this was sacred.
They went to huge lengths
to bring the [inaudible].
The rest of the SAS is from the Marlboro
downs to create the big stone circle at
Stonehenge and then to put
the bluestones inside it.
But initially what they were celebrating
was a natural union of Heaven and
earth. And that brings us
to the notion of as above.
So below that we are connected
to the cosmos, that it is,
that it is part of our heritage. We in
modern cities, forget the cosmos exists.
We have all kinds of tech that can look
at astronomy, astronomy programs. We can,
we don't do that by actually looking
at the stars is something that's very
difficult for people who live in cities
to do where we're cut off from the
cosmos. We're cut off from
the notion that it is sacred,
that it matters to the human creature.
And what what the ancients seem to have
had done is to realize how vital that
connection is and to memorialize it
and to celebrate it and to draw our
attention to the intimate connection
between ground Scott. Yeah.
Light pollution sort of fuels our infant
tile existence and a lot of ways, right?
Because it doesn't constantly remind us
that we're a part of this great thing.